weights parkour and skateboarding plus
he did his own stunts and really got
beat up for those big fight scenes
andrew garfield got ripped for
spider-man here's how
for andrew garfield getting his body
into perfect spider-man shape meant
spending hours in the gym lifting
weights and training the excessive
exercise was just a sacrifice garfield
was willing to make in order to play one
of his dream roles when asked in an
interview to give advice to a kid who
might want the perfect spider-man body
garfield responded frankly dude i i
can't preach about going to the gym
because i whenever i'm not playing
spider-man
not in the gym
garfield admitted that he does enjoy
being active but he's far from a gym rat
his advice to the would-be superhero was
to identify whatever way your body wants
to move and to lean into that activity
saying if line dancing is your thing
just go do line dancing we need to move
our body wants to move but lifting
weights is not for me garfield's trainer
from the amazing spider-man 2 armando
allercon disagrees with the actor on
that point he told coach mag andrew will
say he is not a weights guy but his
physicality and his ability say
otherwise after seeing the amazing
spider-man films we have to agree with
that take
without a deep love for pumping iron in
the gym andrew garfield found himself
relying on some childhood skills and
passions as he began training to become
the wall crawling web slinger garfield
told rte kids that he used to be a
gymnast that history gave him some
familiarity with spider-man's movement
and flexibility and meant that he wasn't
going into his superhero training
entirely cold garfield was also able to
lend some more specific abilities from
his past to the amazing spider-man
franchise he also revealed that he used
to be a skateboarder of course when it
comes to the big stunts that are seen in
the films garfield had the assistance of
wires and the occasional stunt double
but when peter is flexing his skater boy
skills in the first movie that's all
garfield he was able to infuse the
character with his own personality and
hobbies in a way that created a unique
and unforgettable peter parker when it
came time to create a new universe for
the amazing spider-man the filmmakers
also wanted to take an approach to the
action that was different from what had
come before stunt coordinator andy
armstrong agreed to join the project on
the condition that he be allowed to use
practical effects instead of cgi
whenever he possibly could saying not to
knock the earlier movies but they feel
dated now purely because cgi has come a
long way this new film became a very
good opportunity to show what we can do
with real-life stunts luckily for
everyone involved in the amazing
spider-man andrew garfield was more than
ready to take on as many stunts as
possible saying in an interview i do
about 70 of it and then 30 of it is done
by these two incredible stuntmen the
result of all that dedication is web
swinging like fans had never seen before
when spider-man flies above cars in new
york city that's really happening and
more often than not that's really
garfield behind the mask
because andrew garfield was committed to
doing his own stunts and truly embodying
spider-man he had to do much more than
just get into shape to prepare for the
role behind-the-scenes footage shows
some of the off-the-wall training
garfield went through he practiced all
of the climbing and jumps that
spider-man does on a daily basis while
saving the citizens of new york he also
had to familiarize himself with walking
and crawling along strands of webbing
just like the friendly neighborhood hero
in one of the most iconic moments in the
first amazing spider-man film peter
links up strands of webbing to pick up
on vibrations in new york's sewers part
of why it feels so believable is because
garfield really is crawling along those
strands despite how natural garfield
makes it look he let his spider-like
abilities go when the cameras finally
stopped rolling he told total film when
you realize you can manipulate your body
it's empowering but it's just so much
work during production he constantly
tried to think about his environment in
terms of spider-man's abilities but
after everything wrapped he says he
tried to let it go
how much training really went into
andrew garfield's first outing as
spider-man garfield told total film
seven hours a day for four months but
two hours was bodywork and the next
three or four hours was all the other
stuff like the harness stuff gymnastics
parkour training wire work and all of
that but it was like summer camp it was
like circus school just pure fun for
someone who doesn't consider themselves
a fan of going to the gym that's an
extreme amount of physical training of
course it probably helped that it wasn't
all just lifting weights his trainers
also had him on a special diet while
training for the first film garfield
explained it was a lot of bland food and
existential dilemmas with weights in my
hands it was a very confusing time in my
life garfield threw himself into the
challenge of it all and his dedication
not only paid off in the film but also
impressed his trainers over and over
again andy armstrong told the new york
daily news andrew was fabulous he was at
our training facility every day learning
the stuns beating himself up and doing
everything that he could
having the body of a superhero and the
know-how to pull off epic stunts just
wasn't enough for the level of realism
that andrew garfield and everyone else
working on the amazing spider-man wanted
to bring into the project he needed to
be a master at moving his body according
to new york daily news garfield took
parkour classes to learn how to properly
move around the cityscape of new york
and he took yoga classes to learn how to
truly control his body's motion the way
someone with heightened senses might be
able to in addition to the classes
garfield's trainers put mirrors around
the training facility and taped pictures
of iconic spiderman poses to them so the
actor could practice them and memorize
how they felt on his body stunt
coordinator andy armstrong explained you
have a big obligation to the fans to do
your best and create something that's
close to what they've seen in the comic
book world the amazing spider-man
franchise had its ups and downs but
there's no denying that garfield nailed
spider-man's physicality from beginning
to end and truly brought the comic book
to life
in the amazing spider-man 2 peter isn't
just a high school graduate but also a
more experienced hero this meant andrew
garfield's training routine needed to
change to take those extra years of
swinging from buildings and defending
the city into account garfield's trainer
armando allercon said in an interview
with coach mag in the first film we
didn't use a lot of weights but in this
film we did the split was 50 50 with
bodyweight exercises training for the
amazing spider-man 2 began in november
2012 three months before filming started
and continued throughout the entire
production allercon said that he and
garfield would train for an hour or two
a day even on top of 12 to 16 hours of
filming each day the only time they
didn't train was quote if he just
physically couldn't with a schedule full
of battles against electro and rhino who
could blame garfield for needing a break
every now and again
that's a question
that's a question
as anyone who regularly works out knows
diet can be just as important as
exercise when it comes to building
muscle andrew garfield is naturally thin
and has a metabolism that burns through
calories almost as quickly as he
consumes them so his trainers had a real
challenge on their hands when it came to
his diet speaking to coach mag armando
allercon said the only way we could
continue to build muscle was to give him
4 000 to 5 000 calories a day when
filming wrapped on the first amazing
spider-man film garfield told total film
that he rushed to his favorite
restaurant in los angeles for a tres
leches cake which he called the most
beautiful cake you've ever witnessed
even with his body in superhero shape
andrew garfield still had to go the
extra mile to prepare for spider-man's
fight scenes the amazing spider-man 2
has some epic battles between spidey and
his villains and they leave the wall
crawler more beaten down than anything
he dealt with in the past getting
garfield into the proper headspace for
someone who'd just been smacked around
by elektra's energy blasts was the
responsibility of his trainer armando
allercon allercon told coach mag about
his plan for the pre-fight workouts i
wanted to ravage his body so hard that
he understood what it felt like the goal
was to wear garfield down mentally and
physically so he could properly get into
the headspace of a spiderman at the end
of his rope battling with electro pushes
spider-man to the very edge of his
abilities and alercon's workouts which
involved just lifting and constantly
moving pushed garfield to the edge of
his from the stunts to the superhero
body to the true exhaustion of battle
garfield's commitment to bringing
spider-man to life never wavered and the
film was made better for it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you